è la tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e dolcissimo su
iphone habitech ai ragazzi questo è
stato forse il gioco che mi avete
consigliato di più per la rubrica dei
rage game perché mi avete detto favi
questo non è un ray g game questo è il
range game
quindi ragazzi grazie in anticipo perché
so che ci divertiremo tantissimo e alla
prete siamo partiti a prefetto stiamo
salendo senza motivo c'è una cinematica
fantastica degna di avatar
qualcuno dei ragazzi mischia ok hai
mobbing ai b movie the game
ma ragazzi mi dovrebbe spiegare perché
prima è passato king kong ma chi se ne
frega questo mi avete detto che jobs ha
certamente più difficile non riescano
anche a partire dal menu quindi partiamo
da dio
bene ho capito invece ho capito che ci
si muove ma mi manca ancora il salto che
ha perfetto cosa o ficcato muso ok ci
sono gli mancherebbe l'ultimo che stai
perfetto solchi e spanò perché si può
anche sparare visto joe
oggi rogazzo ragazzi è difficile più
difficile di quanto pensassi sta roba
credo che debba andare tipo qui sopra
forza se no non ci credo si può saltare
due volte mio dio
questa è un'innovazione ragazzo ma porca
[ __ ] non è possibile dalla quantità
come fa un ragazzino o morire con una
mela me lo spiegate raga impossibile
gioco infattibile cioè come cazzo faccio
a superare due mini madonna allora
aspettato il secondo non è non è così
vita a [ __ ] non ci credo alla ragazza
volta serie allora ci sono ragazze ma
non posso credere che a trovano è
possibile allora fermi 12 questa deve st
ok perfetto ragazzina come che hanno
fatto sapere le tute numero a tentoni
ole ole ole ok ok ok ci passo passo si
porta un dio mio
incredibile che sta per forza di sotto
per forza
ok ho detto mio dio mio dio mio dio work
at laghi
sorella incastrata nel divano ragazzi
non mi ricordano mai più come ho fatto è
successo una volta non succederà mai più
non mi succederà ma anche questo è
sicuro
ok ok ok ok
si no si ok ci sono ragazzi sono i soldi
ti manca l'ultima ma anche all'ultima
dove tipo saltarla ok ok non ce l'ho
fatta mio piatto vecchia amica di sopra
come ci arrivo di stop
devo saltare tipo immaginavo sulle
nuvole ok ok
cos'è no a vas e cia ma come cazzo si ma
non è possibile
raga per finire sto gioco non
basterebbero 30 ma che cazzo ma si può
essere così [ __ ] dai donna
[Musica]
da nola prima non ci posso credere la
primavera ho detto ok un cazzo ragazzi
non si può fare sto gioco inguardabile
mio dio non sono arrivato al primo c'è
eccome
[Musica]
beh vabbè raga dai non siamo al primo ma
direi dei ragazzi siamo al primo livello
non ho preso un checkpoint sono qui da
mezz'ora ho fatto 4 miliardi di tagli
perché sennò il video lo vedete lungo 4
ore e mezzo di continuare da questo
football e il primo o il secondo o
lesbica tso lui sa dal primo salto al
secondo faccia sopra incredibile in
mezzo a due bancor avanti si sente un
pro della madonna oddio non so come ho
fatto incredibile incredibile
il credit credibile come cazzo si fa sto
pezzo ragazzi che cosa saltano gli
dicono cose ma salta non voglio farmi
ammazzare proprio incazzarmi si ok ci
sono di nuovo ora che incredibile sì va
bene va bene va bene ok ok ok ci risiamo
alla ragazza parte difficile ma ci provo
no no no no si può non messo quattro
aree a parlare è guido ho messo quattro
ore i ragazzi non si può fare sto gioco
è sì ma come pretende come pretendono
questi che io possa farcela in un gioco
del genere è guardabile i ragazzi non si
può fare oddio ragazzo ho provato
[Musica]
tu fai ti prego ti prego non ritengono
abbia fatto adesso senza morire ma anche
una volta non ci posso credere
io dovrei andare insomma stendere andare
in omicidio
oddio no no
la cinese è fatta di merda ragazzi ci ho
messo anni non ci potrò mai più arriva
ai smesso di ti sei accorto che un gioco
di merda hai smesso di funzionare
bravissimo sì sì no no no
basta basta mi arrendo mi arrendo basta
finito qui
non ne voglio assolutamente più sapere
perché mi sono rotto le palle
sì sì sì
poi vai vai cioè ci posso credere
4 potute ore anni diventa di fila che ce
l'ho fatta non ci posso credere praga
dove si allora adesso perfetto ci siamo
voglio vedere se riesco arrivare
all'altro check point ma dubito ma ci
provo lo stesso guai così allora ok
perfetto partiamo di merda ma non me ne
frega niente perché riparto da qui
ragazzi e io mi incazzo si fa sto pezzo
aspettate un attimo né impossibile
ragazzi vi giuro non solo guardare sono
troppo emozionato per esserci riuscito
ma sono cieco io scusate un attimo c'è
un coso lì sotto non c'è e non voglio lo
stesso allora che cazzo serve ragazzi
non ho capito bene st penso che
[Musica]
che figata cazzo ragazzi non so come è
infatti sono caduto subito ho capito
allora ci sono tipo dei così invisibili
credo che ce ne sia un altro tipo qui ok
adesso forse ci arrivo si ok ci siamo
ragazzi ci siamo non ho capito se devo
centrare la strada tipo cosa aspettare
un attimo novecento dalla strada
processo tizio oggi ragazzi restano
centrare la casetta quella vissuta al
vulcano non so se ci riesco ma ci provo
ma è così ok perfetto allora non era nei
miei piani ma va bene lo stesso che sa
dove andare tutto a caso non sto tipo
si ok ok va bene maraga devo farli a
casa finché non ci riesco a impossibile
è lui che scova tutto e lui incredibile
oddio ok ok ok calmi calmi
ero preparatissimo lo preparatissimo o
no no no 20 mag adesso se da te devo
capire perché qui sto alla rapina non ci
posso più andare ad es
a meno che non non penso che ci credo
the game over room rr to try again che
perfetto da non devo non devo premere r
devo prendere quel coso tech e pola
ragazzi si ok ok ho preso qualcosa non
so che cosa è probabilmente un iphone
se qualcuno ha perso un telefono
probabilmente l'ho trovato io quindi va
bene però non so che cosa mi sia servito
questo sono andata a vedere cosa mi
avete scritto nei commenti perché sono
meno dicevate voi non ci riuscivo devo
prendere sta merda di ascensore che già
è un casino prenderlo ma modon
santissima già di pc a prender
calmiamoci tutti un secondo ok allora
una volta preso il telecomando devo
salire qui sopra perché mi avete detto
nei commenti su facebook perché se non
già facevo che devo salire aver
aspettato di mandare qui sopra tu sei
scudetti bio mio cos'è sta roba dai ma
che cazzo a candle essa mai no anno anno
a superman batman
basta questa è veramente l'ultima perché
non ce la faccio più sono stressato devo
andare a bere qualche chilo o litro
quello che volete di camomilla aspettato
il secondo secondo la puoi infilare
lecca pranzi con la punta non so se hai
capito
raga basta basta la finisco qui che cosa
ci fa uno a nap basta mi sono rotto le
palle sto gioco è impossibile possa
sbattere la testa contro il muro forte
chi me l'ha consigliato perché arrivati
nel prossimo video se sono così
disperato da farlo ma per ora è un
chiodo che perché veramente ho bisogno
di una dormita ragazzi sto gioco non fa
bene alla salute
ogni mi piace che mette tra vi do il mio
cervello ritorna normale note video è
piaciuto come al solito alzato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione degli scritti
iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo un prossimo
vito bei ragazzi
[Musica]